today's video is kindly sponsored by
raid shadow legends find out more later
on hey 42 here there's a good chance
you've never noticed it before but your
local fitness gym is hiding a horrifying
secret no not those maniacs who dry
their entire bodies with the hair dryers
i'm referring to a popular piece of gym
equipment with an incredibly sinister
past the treadmill
okay so treadmills might not sound all
that terrifying on the face of it but
bear with me because the world's most
popular piece of gym equipment has a
surprising and disturbing history that
for some reason the world has chosen to
forget
as for what that history is well the
clue's in the name treadmill
tread
mill the tread part makes perfect sense
obviously
but why male well it turns out that not
so long ago that part made perfect sense
too allow me to explain
raid is the first game to bring a true
console level experience to your phone
with hundreds of artifacts to equip and
over 600 champions blessed with unique
skills you can build your team develop
your champions and raid your way i've
been playing raid for a while now and i
have my personal favorite champions i
really like anger the master of insults
anger is a legendary champion from the
void faction who's focused on
controlling the enemy team his skill set
lets him provoke the entire enemy team
first by placing provoked debuffs on
them and after that he buffs his own
team with reflect damage and himself
with counter-attack and next up gorgarab
he's one of the most universal epic
champions in all of raid he's the
full-on support package all-in-one
champion so what's new in raid well this
month is ray's three year anniversary
and the celebrations are going to be
huge but whilst we're waiting check this
out raid's first ever champion skins
they look absolutely amazing and i can't
wait to get my hands on them personally
i like this skin most of all this is the
best time to get started in raid and if
you use my link in the description or
scan my qr code you'll get a free
starter pack worth almost 40 dollars
we're talking free free champions at
once mizeracord tiger soul romero plus
10 magic xp brews 10 force xp brews and
10 spirit brews all this treasure will
be waiting for you here and remember
these rewards will only be available for
the next 30 days and for new players
only once you're in you can find me
in-game under the name 42 and if you're
fast you can join my clan it's that easy
just click the link in the description
and i'll see you in game at the turn of
the 19th century right here in england
there were well over 200 criminal
offences that were punishable by death
amongst them were such heinous crimes as
being in the company of gypsies for one
month
writing a threatening letter and brace
yourself stealing from a rabbit warren i
always knew those cuddly bastards were
hiding something put simply back then if
you broke the law in almost any way you
were basically [ __ ]
this absurdly strict criminal justice
system would eventually come to be known
as the bloody code but it was its very
harshness that catalysed a dramatic
shift in public sentiment towards how
criminals were treated i mean was it
really okay to have someone murdered for
writing a strongly worded letter
assuming they didn't continually use the
wrong spelling of their
probably not but of course such reckless
hate still needed to be punished
somehow
it was this need for an alternative to
capital punishment that saw the number
of state prisons being set up in england
rise dramatically in the early part of
the 19th century by and large
incarceration was seen as a positive
alternative to death but whilst prisons
were clearly a good place to house any
spare criminals you weren't planning on
hanging
not everyone was entirely convinced they
were the best way to encourage those
criminals to change their ways
you're probably familiar with the phrase
there's no rest for the wicked which is
usually used light-heartedly to mean
that work doesn't stop no matter how
tired or busy you may be but the phrase
originally comes from a passage in the
book of isaiah in the old testament of
the bible
that explains how sinners who end up in
the fiery pits of hell will experience
eternal torment and therefore never know
peace or rest again
and that whole concept raised an
interesting question if never-ending
torture was god's way of punishing
evildoers down in hell was prison really
the best solution for dealing with them
up here on earth because in prison which
was basically just a giant building full
of tiny rooms where nobody ever did
anything
there was plenty of rest for the wicked
in the early 19th century this little
discrepancy between the will of god and
the approach taken in england's prisons
came to the attention of a young british
engineer by the name of william cubit
he'd recently visited barry
saint-edmonds jail and been outraged to
witness widespread idleness amongst the
inmates there so outraged in fact that
he decided he was going to do something
about it coming from a family of millers
cubit reasoned that the best thing for
these lazy criminals was to give them a
taste of what genuine hard work looked
like but that was easier said than done
after all there wasn't exactly an
abundance of useful jobs to choose from
nor was there any space for physical
activity cubit needed to come up with a
way of putting large numbers of inmates
to work without taking up too much
precious real estate his solution as i'm
sure you've guessed by now was the
treadmill admittedly cubit's original
design was fairly different to the
treadmills that can be found in homes
and gyms all over the world today it was
basically just a giant rotating wheel
complete with large flat spokes that a
prisoner could climb a bit like an
endless staircase as the wheel rotated
and here's where the mill part of the
name will finally start to make sense
you see the largest treadmills could
accommodate as many as 40 prisoners at
once
and cubit realized he could harness the
energy they generated to do useful
things some prisons use this energy to
pump water or circulate air whilst
others use the treadmills like giant
human powered mills to grind corn in
some cases all the energy was harnessed
to do
absolutely nothing at all with prisoners
working those treadmills jokingly
claiming to be grinding the wind
at this point you might be wondering
what all the fuss is about can a spot of
exercise on one of cubits treadmills
really have been that bad after all
these days people pay good money to
grind the wind on the running machines
and steppers at their local gyms
but we aren't talking about a leisurely
5k followed by a protein shake and half
an hour in the sauna here
prisoners over the age of 16 in england
who were sentenced to hard labor were
forced to work the treadmill seven days
a week for between six and ten hours a
day with minimal breaks during that time
inmates will climb somewhere north of 4
000 vertical meters the equivalent of
scaling mount albert the tallest
mountain in the rockies every single day
now that's pretty insane but the reality
was actually even worse if for some
reason you did climb mount albert every
day
you would at least be rewarded with
lungfuls of crisp mountain air
incredible views and that exquisite
feeling of superiority over all your
friends every time you posted a summit
picture on instagram but prisoners who
were forced to work the treadmill
had no such return on their physical
investment
the machines were carefully designed to
make the whole experience as
mind-numbing as possible most were built
inside enclosed stalls meaning that far
from having a lovely view
prisoners had no choice but to stare at
a blank featureless wall hour after hour
as they climbed and many prisons added
partitions to prevent inmates from
talking or even seeing each other to top
it all off prison rations were woefully
inadequate for such a relentless
schedule of physical exertion meaning
prisoners would slowly grow weak and
sickly as their sentences dragged on
which only served to make each day
harder than the last
this combination of brutal physical
hardship and mind-numbing boredom
brought about by almost total sensory
deprivation made the treadmill not just
an incredibly grueling form of
punishment but a genuinely cruel one too
hardened criminals frequently collapsed
midway through a shift particularly in
the summer months
and there are reports of formerly
sanguine individuals becoming more or
less unhinged by week after week of
monotonous stair climbing in a few cases
the ordeal is even forced to have proven
fatal probably the most famous person
ever to have been made to walk the
treadmill is none other than legendary
author and playwright oscar wilde who in
1895 was imprisoned for the heinous
crime of being a homosexual
as part of his sentence wilde was forced
to suffer on the treadmill at
pentonville prison in london for a
period of three months and he was left
so exhausted and weakened by this
experience he collapsed one day in the
prison chapel it was a nasty fall and
wilde came away from it with a ruptured
eardrum an injury that some doctors
believe contributed to his death which
came just two years after he was
released from prison at the age of 46.
despite its incredible cruelty for a
long time the treadmill was seen as a
great success
largely thanks to a deluge of glowing
five-star reviews from prison wardens
who invariably reported less trouble
amongst inmates after a treadmill was
installed not that that's exactly a big
surprise in order to make trouble you
have to actually move something that
prisoners who used a treadmill for eight
hours a day
were understandably disinclined to do by
the end of the 19th century there was
almost 40 treadmills in use in prisons
around britain with several institutions
in the u.s and beyond also adopting the
technology
but over the years it seems the powers
that be slowly came to the shocking
realization that prisoners are actually
human beings too
and that both physically and mentally
torturing them was well all things
considered
probably a bit unnecessary the treadmill
was finally banned in england in 1902
and that should probably have been that
but some 60 years later an enterprising
american chap by the name of william
storm saw a new use for this outlawed
torture of prisoners
home fitness
treadmill-like devices were already
being used by doctors to test patient
heart rates at the time but it was storm
who first saw a gap in the market for a
running machine that could be used at
home and what a colossal gap it turned
out to be as of today the treadmill is
the world's most popular piece of gym
equipment by quite a distance
with global sales topping 3 billion
dollars
in 2020
of course it's hard to miss the irony
here
these days not only do people willingly
jump on these literal torture devices
they usually pay large sums of money for
the privilege but then as is often the
case context is everything in the hands
of a surgeon in an operating theatre a
scalpel is a life-saving tool
wielded by a thug in a street fight it's
a lethal weapon the same can be said of
the treadmill in a prison setting where
people were forced to use it for up to
10 hours a day it was a brutal torture
device
but when you can push the big red stop
button whenever you feel like it
it's just one of the perks of a hundred
pound a month gym membership
thanks for watching